being victimized by a circumstance in
your life literally means that that
event that circumstance that person that
condition is actually causing you to
feel emotionally and think in terms of
memories equal to that circumstance and
that circumstances actually changes your
state of being so you're thinking the
same way and you're feeling the same way
in response to the environment is the
same we can guarantee that your life is
going to stay the same because you're
the same yes that person why are you
unhappy why are you frustrated why are
you sad they'll say that this condition
this this person is actually making me
feel and think this way well anything
that makes us feel and think a certain
way that we don't think we have any
control over for the most part we're
victims so we're as a species become
victimized by the conditions in our life
and it's the environment then that is
controlling the way we feel in the way
we think so the idea is if you can
change the way you think and change the
way you feel could you begin to reduce
outcomes or effects in your life that
cause you to believe that you're the
creator of your life instead of the
victim of your life need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
seven Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going I had
no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories motivation
today so today this one from one of the
best Joe dispenza and my take on his top
10 rules of success enjoy
the synchronicity of the Serendipity the
coincidence that happens in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to realize that
on some level you had a hand in that you
know that you were a participant in that
our interest is to teach people how to
to reverse that process
every person every circumstance every
condition every place every object that
you own is mapped neurologically in your
brain so your brain is a record of the
past it's it's an artifact the
repository of everything you've learned
intellectually or experience and
products of experience are called
emotions the memories that we have in
our life produces familiar emotions or
our response to anybody that we know in
our life there's a neurological Network
for your boss for your co-worker for
your ex and for most people they're
they're interaction in the environment
is causing their environment to control
their thinking or their personal reality
is controlling their personality so our
interest is see us of oh if your
personality is made of how you think how
you act and how you feel
is it possible if I begin to change the
way I think change the way I act and
change the way life I feel should my
life change because I'm changing and so
the interest for us then is to be able
to meet the challenges and conditions in
our life from a greater level of
Consciousness and and not be victimized
by those circumstances but to take time
and and to review how you're going to
think how you're going to act and how
you're going to feel that's meditation
and review how you're not going to think
you know how you're not going to act and
how you're not going to feel it just
turns out that tends to be 95 percent of
who we are as those unconscious programs
so it's so much easier to forget than to
remember because it's the majority of
who we are you know after a certain
point in our life so changing that
process the overcoming process of that
same self somehow begins to produce a
facts in people's lives and that's
that's kind of the exciting part about
being a creator of your life rule number
two is pay attention to your actions I
always tell my children that your
personality creates your personal
reality and if you want to change
something in your life then on a
fundamental level you have to look at
the thoughts you're thinking to see if
they're serving you notice the behaviors
and that you're demonstrating and see if
those are loving to yourself and begin
to look at the emotions that you've
memorized that become part of your
identity and children begin to
understand this very naturally because
the law with children
that I've believed from the time my
children were very young is that if you
give them the facts they will interpret
the laws so because of mirror neurons
your children are paying attention to
more of what you do than what you say
so you can't say to your kids clean your
room and have a messy room you
understand because they're going to want
they're going to look at your room
subconsciously automatically
and I was on uh interviewing doing an
interview for this book someone was
interviewing interviewing for me for
this book and they said can you tell me
about the terrible twos I said it's
really simple
what do you do the first uh year of your
child's life
oh look how cute he is look how cute she
is look oh and then all of a sudden at
one years old what happens
they stand up right and they stand up
and their brain is so neuroplastic and
they go wow look at this vase I wonder
how it's made oh it holds water and then
it begins the child begins to interact
with the environment out of curiosity
pulling things breaking things and then
what do you do
no
you do that for a whole year and then
you say a two years old put your shoes
on and what's the child say no
that's mirror neurons it's only
mirroring Behavior so we know then that
children pay attention because of those
mirror neurons more based on what they
observe than what they're told rule
number three is practice repetition
every time you learn something new you
make new Connections in your brain
that's what learning is learning is
forging new synaptic connections
and as you begin to leave imprints in
your neurological tissue as a result of
your interaction in the environment
the next thing is that you're going to
have an opportunity then to apply that
information
to personalize it to demonstrate it
and a certain people group of people
will get their behaviors to match their
intentions
to get their actions equal to their
thoughts they'll step out into the
unknown
and let's try it
and when they do they'll have a new
experience
and experience then enriches the brain
reorganizing more circuits than what you
understood physiologically
but the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and the moment you feel Unlimited
the moment you feel like a patient
parent the moment you feel abundant the
moment you feel free
now you are teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood
so we can say knowledge is for the mind
and experiences for the body
and in that moment you're beginning to
embody the truth of that philosophy of
that theory and you're literally
signaling new genes in new ways and you
are rewriting your biological program
but if you've done it once
it must mean you can do it again
and if you can repeat any experience
over and over again you are going to
neurochemically condition your mind and
body to begin to work as one
and we've done something so many times
that the body now knows how to do it as
well as the mind now it's becoming
innate in you
it's second nature it's easy it's
familiar
it's who you are
as a matter of fact you've practiced it
so many times that you don't even have
to consciously think about it because
it's becoming a subconscious program
so our job
is to go from philosopher
to initiate to master
from knowledge to experience to wisdom
from mind to body to Soul
from thinking to doing to being to
learning it with your head practicing it
with your hands and knowing it by heart
rule number four is change your brain
waves the whole purpose of meditation is
to get beyond the analytical mind and
what separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind is the analytical
mind and so we'll talk about that in a
minute but we teach people how to create
coherent brains and of course we also
teach them and they understand that when
they're resentful or they're impatient
or they're frustrated their heart also
beats incoherently as well so then is it
possible then to train them to regulate
their autonomic nervous system by
changing their brain waves and by
changing their heart coherence so then
they can begin to transform themselves
and transform matter and that's kind of
the model that we use next slide quick
little overview on brain waves here look
at the top one there it says beta brain
waves you can see they're pretty fast
your brain's job is to create meaning or
coherence between what's going on in
your outer world and what's going on in
your inner world most people function in
beta brainwave patterns when they're
awake and they wake up in the morning
and their brain starts making serotonin
they start to use their senses and
they're integrating everything through
their senses and their brains trying to
process all that information into
meaning so they're sitting there feeling
pain they're tired they're hungry they
have the light on they're doing a few
things and the brain's got to deal with
all that information so brain waves in
the thinking brain are pretty quick when
you close your eyes and you eliminate
your external environment as an example
your brain kind of slows down in brain
waves because it's processing less
information so now you're in Alpha and
Alpha instead of the outer World being
more real the inner world starts
becoming more real when your body falls
asleep and your mind is awake you move
into what's called Theta brainwave
patterns that's a good place to be
because if you've conditioned your body
to be the mind then your body's asleep
and your mind is awake that means it's
no longer the mind then you can fall
right into some pretty quick changes and
reprogram those automatic programs Delta
of course is restorative sleep and we
won't have time to get into gamma but I
call gamma super Consciousness or super
awareness that's when the brain is
aroused but instead of because of some
predators some threat in the environment
the brain is aroused because the
sympathetic nervous system is switched
on and it's releasing energy instead of
out of the body up into the brain and
the person's really has all their
attention on the inner experience
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is Master your
emotions I'm curious uh why is it that
as humans we default to this fear-based
thinking it's so hardwired in us as a
species that's lived in survival for
for so many thousands of years and in
survival you know fear is really
adaptive if you want to survive that
chemical Rush is telling you that
there's danger or there's a threat and
to run from that danger or stay off and
face the conflict you know that was kind
of the model of of survival of the
fittest so when we perceive the problems
and challenges in our life and it evokes
fear right like and because we don't
think we can control it or we can't
predict it or it looks like things could
get worse that's what turns on that
primitive nervous system that puts you
in a state of alarm in a state of
arousal and we're just been bred for
thousands of years to to live in
survival and turns out that when we we
live in those States for extended
periods of time it has biological felt
effects on the health of the body but
but to the person the arousal then
becomes something stimulating
so without knowing it they they start
relying on the response to stimulate
their body to keep it awake to keep it
alive and then they can think about
their problems in the same exact way and
produce that arousal and keep the body
in a state of a you know state of
emergency
turns out it gets a little addictive
after a while and and then we start
using the people and problems in our
life to reaffirm that addiction to that
emotion and we're addicted to a a life a
miserable life we don't even like you
know and that's why change becomes so
hard because that becomes the known that
becomes the familiar and you're always
you know anticipating the next moment
but that's a default it's hardwired in
the human being because survival was
adaptive at one point but fast forward
to now and and the conditions and are no
longer T-Rex chasing you they're just a
little bit more complex and it requires
a lot of uncertainty and a lot of
unpredictability and that's exactly what
creates the hormones of stress so our
response to the environment has to
change and that's what we practice doing
because when you're no longer responding
to the same conditions in the same
emotional way I think when you master
your emotions you master your Creations
things start to change in your life rule
number six is focus on the future from
my last five years of traveling around
the world the common people that look
just like you were doing the uncommon
they're healing themselves of very
serious health conditions
they're creating better opportunities
and better lives for themselves new
careers they're healing old scars and
wounds that kept them connected to the
Past
and they're having mystical experiences
that transcend language that take them
years to be able to understand and
explain
and they look just like you
that most people in their life wait for
that crisis or the trauma the disease
the diagnosis some kind of loss betrayal
in their life before they make up their
mind to change
and my message has always been why wait
why wait for that tragedy before you
decide to change who you are
that when you begin to apply these
principles because you understand that
they work
then it means then you'll believe in a
future more than you believe in your
past
and people who do the work are more in
love with their future than they are
with their past
and they're more interested in telling
the story of possibility in their future
than reliving the emotions and
experiences of the past rule number
seven is break bad habits the change is
to be greater than your environment that
means be greater than the conditions in
your life to be greater than the
circumstances in your world in every
great person in history knew this that
means you have to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memories of
the past to change means be greater than
your body those unconscious habits and
behaviors and choices that you've made
over and over again so many times that
the body becomes the Mind emotions that
are connected to past experiences keep
you anchored emotionally to the past and
if those emotions are driving your
thoughts and those thoughts are creating
the same emotions then your body has
become the mind which means that in
order for you to change you're going to
have to get greater than those emotional
reactions habits and hardwired attitudes
that keep you running unconscious
programs and to change then is to be
greater than time if you're waking up
every single day and making the same
choices and demonstrating the same
behaviors and creating the same
experiences and you do that over and
over again it makes sense that your past
is going to look a lot like your future
and your future will be more of your
past finding The Sweet Spot of the
generous present moment existing in that
place where you're no longer trying to
predict a future based on the past means
you're in the unknown and when you're in
that place called The Eternal present
moment that's where all possibilities
exist give it a try rule number eight is
manage your stress is it possible then
if your thoughts can make you sick your
thoughts can make you well
and that's exactly what our research
shows you keep thinking the same way you
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep having
the same experiences and reacting to the
same conditions with the same emotions
for the most part your genes and your
brain and everything is going to stay
the same in your blood values because
you're the same so then the process of
thinking differently making different
choices doing different things creating
different experiences and feeling
different emotions if you do that for
seven days
you have significant changes that take
place on a cellular level on your brain
in in just about every part of your
biology because you're you're you're
making those changes our discoveries
really have to do with showing people
that their nervous system is the
greatest Pharmacy in the world that it
that it makes chemicals that work better
than any drug we can say that with with
such certainty when a person moves into
into these states
the Practical part of it all the time is
is the daily practice people in our work
that do this work they do it really
because they understand what they're
doing and why they're doing it and when
you combine the what and the why the how
tends to get easier I love what you said
about the nervous system being sort of
the greatest Pharmacy because I don't
think we know the power of our bodies
the power of our health the power of
coherence yeah well that's a great
question because the people who live in
stress are living in survival as they
try to control and predict everything
that takes place in their life every
person every object every circumstance
has a neurological Network in the brain
and the arousal of the stress hormones
shifts our attention very quickly to all
these elements in our lives and our
brains literally start firing out of
order they start firing like a lightning
storm and the clouds very incoherently
and networks of neurons start working
separately from one another they come
departmentalize when the brain is
incoherent we're incoherent when the
brain isn't working right we're not
working right the heart which is now
pumping an enormous amount of blood
against the closed system the the
arteries aren't you're not running
you're not fighting so the pressure
against the heart causes the heart to be
very incoherently and in that state
energy goes down in the heart
incoherence creates a loss of energy
both in the heart and the brain so that
kind of dysregulation that takes place
in the nervous system begins to send
very incoherent messages through the
autonomic nervous system to all the
cells and tissues and organs in the body
and the brain is now really over focused
you know when you're in stress you're
really thinking a lot you're thinking
about the same thing over and over again
it's looping and that looping actually
within that emotional state is actually
driving your brain to become more and
more analytical and moving into very
high brainwave States you're narrowing
your focus on something and that's what
we do when the arousal of stress causes
us to pinpoint our focus on a person on
circumstance on that problem a thought
whatever it is that that cycle then is
continuously causing the body to move
out of balance just because the brain
and the heart are sending signals to the
body that are that the cells don't
understand it's not coherent that's
autonomic dysregulation rule number nine
is meditate how you think and how you
feel creates your state of being
and you're thinking the same thoughts
that are creating the same feelings and
same emotions and those emotions are
influencing your thoughts would you
agree then you're signaling that same
gene over and over again and if genes
are responsible for the structure and
the function of the body and you keep
selecting and instructing the same gene
you're going to wear that Gene out
yes or no just like gears in your car
picking a fax of a facts of a facts of a
fax or a copy of a copy of a copy sooner
or later it's going to lose its detail
yes or no that's exactly what happens to
the body the body begins to break down
because those proteins are responsible
for your physiology for your structure
so then if immune cells make immune
proteins
and you're living in fear every single
day
you're living in anger and resentment
and impatience every single day then
you're signaling the same gene in the
same way yes or no
and if you keep doing that for a period
of time sooner or later you're going to
program that Gene and all of a sudden
the body is going to get unhealthy yes
or no
and look you know people say well I did
my meditation
three days and nothing happened
but I tell them how long did it take you
to create that condition tell me
so then if meditation means to become
familiar with
you got to become more familiar with the
thoughts behaviors and emotions of your
future than familiar with the thoughts
and behaviors emotions of your past yes
or no
so then if you keep firing and wiring
the same circuits in your brain
installing the circuits the hardware
becomes a software program and it gets
easier to think in unlimited ways it
gets easier to act like a wealthy person
it becomes easier than to cultivate the
emotions of your future instead of the
emotions of your past and number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is learn to let go most of us tell
the story of our past in a negative
Sense on how it's held us back
um
millions of times over our life as
opposed to the story of the future of
what we want to create or who we want to
become
yeah listen again you tell that story in
the latest research on memory says that
memory is creative that in fact 50 of
that story you embellish people make up
that story let me tell you why they make
up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
it's less of the truth because you got
to work yourself up into a state there
were lions and tigers and there was
right you know they were helicopters
snowstorms everybody was firing bullets
the worst thing you could possibly
imagine and then you've got to feel that
emotion right and then you're looking oh
yeah it must have been really bad now
that's that's your identity now that's
your identity
the more you hold on to that identity of
the past the harder it is to become who
you want to be in the future well here's
here's to answer the other part of your
question when we started talking
how do you get that person out of their
past yeah well we need a week it's not
going to happen it doesn't happen
overnight no I want them to come right
up against their fear I want them to
come right up against their doubt I want
them to come up against the point where
they're going to give up and quit and
they're going to sit there and nobody
else is giving up and quitting and
they're going to go all in more and
they're going to start believing what
there's something on the other side of
that emotion they're going to believe
that there's something past the story of
their past because they're stretching
themselves out of the known and it takes
a tremendous amount of awareness
repetition information model building
sharing understanding experiencing to
finally have a person get to the point
where they just let go and when they do
the body's liberated from the past and
there's a release of energy and we now
know that there's a formula to teach
people how to do that in fact we're
getting so good at it that the first two
days a day and a half sometimes one day
in certain groups of a week-long event
is about retiring that past finishing it
you know this is when the story ends
this is when they get over it now the
next five days
the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genes they're going to be
interchanged to brain circuitry their
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression they're telling me
is it's all going to happen they're
they're more of that future self and and
they're they're headed to a future now
here's the deal though you got to be
able to sustain that state when you
return back to your life that's the name
of the game you got to be able right you
got to bring the game into your life now
and no person no circumstance no
condition in your life would cause you
to feel the old way again because the
moment you started feeling victimized
the moment you started feeling angry you
just returned to the old self you
disconnected from the energy of your
future and you're back to the energy of
your past
the concept of transformation is a
really important message and and we use
meditation as
the mechanism because I want people to
become so familiar with their old
personality self that they don't default
anymore and keep reaffirming that new
personality it's so much easier to
forget that Vision than to remember so
you gotta constantly remind yourself
reproduce the same level of line you've
got to constantly emotionally embrace it
keep conditioning the body the thought
and the feeling the image and the
emotion the stimulus and response your
conditioning your body into the future
instead of waking up every morning and
remembering your problems and those
problems are associated with people and
objects of things at certain times and
places and every one of those problems
as an emotional associate so people are
remembering their past and they're
feeling the emotions they're firing and
wiring the same circuits and feeling the
same ocean they're conditioning their
body into the past and that's why change
is so hard
because the moment you step out from
doing the same thing and making a
different choice there's going to be
some discomfort because the body
subconsciously has been programmed
emotionally into the past
so the moment you make a different
Choice you're stepping out of the known
into the unknown the body starts
influencing the mind to return back to
the familiar place that's why people
have difficulty changing and yet if
meditation is the model
to become so familiar with your old self
and so familiar with your new self how
many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment called
change okay give people the tools and
let them practice and they'll actually
start enjoying it okay but if
you're not being defined by a vision of
the future
I assert you're left with the memories
of the past and you'll be predictable in
your life so you wake up in the morning
you see your co-worker you see your
husband you see you're on a zoom call
you're picking up your cell phone for
most people it's the environment that's
actually causing them to think and feel
equal to everything that they know so
it's not their personality that's
creating their personal reality it's
their personal reality that's
reaffirming their personality it's their
environment that's controlling the way
they feel and the way they think why
because every person
your husband your co-workers your your
employees
your dog your cell phone every one of
those things you have a neurological
Network that you've actually created
because you've experienced them and
because you've experienced them you have
an emotion associated with them so if
we're not being defined by a vision of
the future when we see the same people
and go to the same places and we do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
the environment is controlling the way
we feel and the way we think but of how
we think and how we feel actually
creates our life as long as we're
thinking equal to everything that we
know everything stays the same because
nothing changes in our life until we
change okay so the conditioning process
the thought and the feeling the memory
and the emotion you're thinking in the
past when you remember your problems you
feel the emotion associated with it
you're conditioning your body to become
the mind of that emotion and it's so
objective it's believing it's living the
same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year and
now you're headed in a very specific
genetic outcome
okay you get up you get up in the
morning you do the same thing yeah as
you did yesterday you go through this
whole routine and you keep doing that
your body's on autopilot now and a habit
is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition happens when you've done
something so many times the body
actually knows not to do it better than
your conscious mind that means your body
is the mind that's dragging you into
that predictable future based on what
you did in the past and you lost your
free will to a set of programs your body
rejects viruses all the time of course
it has memorized certain viruses that
you've been exposed to it's memorized
certain bacteria that you've been
exposed to and it's beaten those viruses
it's not every virus wins in the body
the body has an intelligence and it's
and it has quite a library memories in
the in the in the white blood cells so
your body is fighting viruses and
bacteria all the time there's got
constant competition going on really so
our research shows that four days of
opening your heart releases
immunoglobulin a your body's primary
defense against bacteria and viruses
it's better than the flu shot it's the
body's natural flu shot and that's the
innate intelligence the body's saying I
got this I got a lot of energy in fact I
got a surplus of energy in fact I'm
radiating energy and now too much out of
the world it will now my outer world is
not controlling my inner world my inner
world now is functioning independent of
what's going on in my outer world and
now my manifesting you're manifesting ah
now you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy to heal and our research shows
that that field around your body will
actually expand you you radiate more
light in information cells are getting
new information that that are causing uh
um light to be exchanged between cells
and information now the body's getting
enough right so so that immunoglobulin a
in four days went up 50 percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then causes another chemical to activate
the arteries in your heart to swell and
now just like when energy moves into
your sexual organs and it swells with
blood and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart and
now now the heart is activated and what
do you feel you feel an incredible
amount of love Yeah and love feel you
feel you feel whole and now the more
whole you feel our research shows then
the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because you
feel like you already have them you only
want things when you're in lack but when
you feel whole then it feels like it's
already happened and that tends to be
the exact emotion that causes those
synchronicities and serendipities and
coincidences to happen in our life and
you say to a person what are you doing
and they're saying I'm not doing
anything I'm I'm just a loving life I'm
being myself I'm free I'm free from the
past I'm free from my story of the past
time in fact I'm more connected to the
energy of my future than I am to the
energy of my past how do you become
Supernatural
well you have to first start doing what
feels unnatural that means when
everybody else is in fear that's when
you show courage when everybody else is
hostile and angry that's the time to
show love and compassion when everybody
else is
um in lack in poverty that's the time to
give and and I think that that gives
people permission to do the same because
of mere neurons we want to emulate that
behavior and it counts the most
in those moments doesn't count when
everything is comfortable and okay it
counts the most
when you should be doing something else
and if you're able to go against those
years thousands of years of genetic
programming hardwired into our survival
centers all of a sudden other people
will begin to do the same and you will
see an emergence of the new
Consciousness you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking are slipping by their
awareness unnoticed because they're
hardwired in their brain because they've
been saying I can't it's too hard my
life will never change in someone else's
fault those thoughts have consequences
in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice how they're
feeling they're no longer the program
they're the Consciousness outside the
program and that's the first step to
change so
there are there are when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and you're tweeting
and your Instagraming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling
but I now know that if you take a person
and you say Okay close your eyes sit in
the in the Silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay I'm gonna
feed you you can check your cell phone
you can shower you can have your coffee
but when I say
and so then Here Comes The Challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in The Familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say I
think I'm meditating wrong I always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and check your cell
phone or have a cup of coffee and you
become aware that it's on autopilot and
wants to do that and you say uh come on
over here and you return it back to the
present moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
a third of mine now we've researched
this
and it's tedious in the beginning at
first because David is fighting Goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal sooner or later the
body acquiesces sooner the later the
body is trained to a new mind and when
that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're they're working and lowering
the volume of that emotion the more they
lower the volume of that emotion the
more they're going to take their
attention off that person and problem
and they're going to take their power
back there's going to be a break and
their attention from that circumstance
and now they build their own field and
now there's energy to heal now there's
energy to create a new life now there's
energy for the mystical moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
I think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming overcoming overcoming
overcoming until we become somebody else
and when that occurs and the person
starts thinking differently and they
start acting differently and they start
feeling differently their new
personality and they they start seeing
those synchronicities and serendipities
what does gratitude do for us in
replacing that kind of anxiety and fear
well I mean uh we've done research on
gratitude and it's very interesting
because when you receive something
you've just received something
uh when something's happening to you or
something just happened to you that's
favorable you feel this feeling of
gratitude so yes the emotional signature
it's signature emotionally means
something just happened to you or
something is happening to you
so your body is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between an experience in your life that
creates an emotion and an emotion that
you can fabricate by thought alone to
the body it's so objective it's exactly
the same so when people start to feel
gratitude
their body is believing that something
favorable is going to happen to them
or has already happened to them really
the emotional signature of gratitude is
the perfect signature or the state of
energy to receive
so so when we begin to embrace our
future and we give we feel gratitude for
it we will believe that future is more
of a reality because it's equal to the
emotion that we're experiencing but
we're feeling the emotion before the
actual event occurs so gratitude in a
sense you could use it to elevate your
energy and when you do just 10 15
minutes a day
you'll strengthen your immune system by
50 percent wow just by having gratitude
for 10 15 minutes yes because your body
starts to put energy right in your heart
center and there's a gland in there that
we talked about in your show called that
plan that has an endocrinological aspect
and immunological aspect and it begins
to Signal chemicals that tells your T
cells strengthen you got energy to like
modify and create more receptors for
anything coming out and now your inner
environment is doing that and your T
cells make these antibodies these
immunoglobulins that are the body's
natural flu shot it's proteins that
protect cells especially immune cells
and now you have an internal Army an
internal order that that will be greater
than the environment and now you have
now you have strength what is healing
for you
um I think people come to our work
Florence for all kinds of reasons they
they come to heal
they come to find love
they come to or to get beyond their
traumas of the past they come for a
mystical experience they come for wealth
or abundance
um but really I think where people
really come for is wholeness and and and
when you see brain and hard coherence uh
this this this Union of the two of the
of the heart and the mind or the heart
and the Brain
um there is a sense of wholeness there
is a sense of healing and
I think if you heal your heart
you heal your mind
I think you heal your mind do you you
heal your heart uh uh and when people
finally Break Free
from those chains of the emotions that
they lived by on a daily basis when they
break free of their habituations even in
the way they speak when they overcome
their hard-wired beliefs that they've
thought over and over again until they
accepted him without without any
analysis
when they overcome that programming uh
to a certain degree
uh they that wholeness that they feel
is uh the healing in and of itself
they're not waiting for their healing or
their health to change so they could
feel gratitude so they could feel whole
they actually understand that when they
feel gratitude and they still feel
wholeness that's when their Healing
Begins so then anything that causes us
to move out of that state
within us
a reaction or response from someone or
something in our life that would move us
from that state of grace
I promise you if you're truly in the
river of change and you wanted to heal
you would think about how you would
respond differently
to that person or circumstance the next
time so you wouldn't lose that feeling
because you would actually no longer be
signaling the same genes in the same way
the moment you felt familiar emotions
you would be signaling old genes and so
the person who understands the what
in what they're doing and the why that
if I live by this emotional state every
single day if the environment signals
the gene okay
and the end product of an experience in
the environment is an emotion if I live
by this emotion I could signal genes of
head of my environment and I could
actually change my health
now this is when meditation no longer
becomes a have to
this is now when meditation becomes very
practical because the person is going to
rehearse in their mind
how they are going to think in their day
what they are going to believe and
they're going to repeat it enough times
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until it
becomes hardwired in your brain they're
going to review that belief and they're
going to keep firing and wiring it
they're going to change the way they
respond to their co-worker to their
spouse uh to their to their boss to the
news they're going to change their
response and they're going to rehearse
it in their mind the mental rehearsal as
you know changes the brain to look like
it's already happened they're going to
say I gotta feel this feeling
if it takes me a hundred times today
to feel this feeling I'm going to bring
it up a hundred times over and over
again so I get so good at feeling it I
can bring it up whenever I want
and stop from default right
and then when people do that that the
overcoming process is the becoming
process that so many people have healed
in this work
and they didn't even realize that when
they were sitting and their body was
raging and out of balance and they were
working with settling it down and
overcoming those survival emotions
overcoming those programs those
habituations that that overcoming
process was actually the becoming
process so many people when they
actually got to the point where they
were so happy with themselves
so in love with themselves so in love
with life so grateful for being like
they could care less
if they had their health condition they
no longer identified with it any longer
that was the moment it went away and you
ask that person where where is the the
the
disease they'll tell you it's in the old
person they healed themselves by
changing themselves they they're happy
with themselves now they don't want to
be anybody else I learned a lot about
expectation when I was studying uh the
placebo you know it's amazing how you
can give someone a sugar pill or a
saline injection or perform some false
surgery or treatment
and a certain percentage of those people
will accept believe and surrender to the
thought
that it's actually the truth without
analyzing it that they're getting an
actual real substance and their body
begins to manufacture the very Pharmacy
of chemicals
that causes them to heal by thought
alone so the question is is it the you
know inert exogenous substance that's
doing the healing or is it the body's
innate capacity to heal so so everybody
has been conditioned to a certain degree
whether we like it or not to rely on
something outside of us
to change our inner State and and and so
when a person's given a pill and it's
and it's blue on one side and red on the
other and they take it and they notice a
change in their internal State my pain
has gone away uh I'm sleeping better
whatever it is
and when they notice that change in
their internal State they pay attention
to what caused it and they start to
associate and condition so well if you
keep doing that over and over again
uh that pill uh becomes a symbol of them
to change their physiology so if you
take that pill and you replace it with
something that's a nerd and they see
that pill based on conditioning when
they take that pill conditioning based
on the past they begin to expect
that outcome to happen again and the
expectation of the outcome is simply
marrying a a a possibility an intention
a vision of a future outcome a new
possibility in the quantum field
and if the doctor's enthusiastic and you
name the substance something that you
can't pronounce and you charge a lot of
money for it and you use a name that
rhymes with something that could
actually you could associate as a known
uh you know Niagara and Viagra there's a
strong correlation it's a lot of flow
and and so people are conditioned to
expect an outcome so
when they start to expect the outcome
the marrying of that clear intention if
the person is optimistic if the person
is enthusiastic if the person is uh uh
grateful for the outcome a combination
of that clear intention combined with
the elevated emotion
begins to change the body's physiology
for them to manufacture their own
Pharmacy of antidepressants their own
Pharmacy of morphines or pain relievers
their own Pharmacy of dopamine by
thought alone so the question is do you
need the exogenous substance to change
your state of being or can you change
your state of being by thought alone
and by the same means if you give a
person a prognosis and you tell them
that in the chemotherapy treatments you
are going to get really nauseous and
sick they've done research on this fifty
percent of the people on their Drive
to the chemotherapy treatment start to
get nauseous in anticipation of the
event taking place so the question is
can 50 of the people get well on their
drive to work or they're on their drive
to their doctor and anticipation in
anticipation of getting the right
treatment in your studies with the power
of aid
if the person can assign meaning
to the value of what they're doing and
they can see oh my God energy can
actually inform matter okay that sounds
like something that makes sense give me
the quantum understanding
and you get a collective group of people
and we're discovering that Collective
networks of Observers determine reality
and you can get them in a very specific
State and the person who's receiving the
healing understands the the value of
what's taking place
the expectation of what's about to
happen if they're in a state of
gratitude it's kind of an interesting
thing gratitude when we receive
something when we've just received
something favorable when something's
happening to us that we really enjoy or
something just happened to us that
surprises us we feel gratitude so the
emotional signature of gratitude is
something's happening to us or something
favorable just happened to it it is the
ultimate state that we receive in so if
the person's in that state of gratitude
then it makes sense then they're more
susceptible to information because we
accept believe and surrender to
information equal to our emotional state
so that can actually program the
autonomic nervous system to begin to
physiologically change and that's
exactly what Pavlov did with the
salivating dogs just ring the bell and
feed them a meal and after a while the
anticipation
of the event actually causes them to
change their body's physiology their
autonomic nervous system begins to
change as if they're actually in the
process of eating the meal the
anticipation is preparing for the event
ahead of time and we can use that to so
many degrees in our favor the moment we
switch on that system for alert or for
emergency
we alter ourselves in some way and and
all of that response that we have to an
environment that we perceive as
threatening or dangerous
um pretty much causes us to move out of
balance and when you're out of balance
you're you're in survival when you're in
survival
you want to rush to get things done you
can't be present you know you uh you
believe everything that equal to the
feeling of fear or hostility because
information is is relevant to you in
that emotional state so uh teaching
people then that they have some type of
control over that that sympathetic
response that emergency system that
switches on is preparing you for
something you can't predict yeah
something that's an unknown something uh
that you can control and
um that survival system uh causes us to
move more into our animal nature and
we're tapping our bodies vital resources
for health and regeneration
so short term it's great but you keep
doing it over and over again you start
becoming more and more conditioned to
that Rush of energy
so teaching people how to self-regulate
teaching them how to move back into the
present moment teaching them
that they can shorten their responses
it's it's really not that you react I
mean we all react the question is how
long are you going to react for because
if you keep that reaction going then
then you can't perceive any change in
your environment you won't have any
ability to heal so you become more uh
affected by your environment so simple
process of getting back into the present
moment to
self-regulating trading that fear uh to
for some other emotions yeah and that
that's doing the work and and the
practice and that's what we should be
doing because now we have energy to heal
we have energy repair we have energy
um to create now most people try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work we
literally have to become someone else in
other words thoughts are the language of
the brain and feelings are the language
of the body and how you think and how
you feel creates a state of being so
most people have experiences in their
life that brand them emotionally they
feel fear they feel anger they feel
bitterness they feel frustration they
feel insecurity and those emotions then
become part of their identity so once
they think certain thoughts that turn on
certain circuits in their brain that are
equal to their insecurity and then they
feel insecure the moment they feel
insecure they think more insecure
thoughts which makes more chemicals for
them to feel insecure and the repetition
of that cycle over time conditions the
body to subconsciously become the mind
of insecurity so then the person says I
am insecure and whenever you say I am
anything you're commanding your mind and
body towards a destiny so then most
people's
biology is for the most part their past
and so if you're not being defined by
the vision of the future some new
possibility in your life you're only
left with the old circuitry in your
brain and the old emotions of the past
so the question then is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the experience has already
occurred now the latest research in
Neuroscience says you can change your
brain just by thinking
so then as you begin to think about a
new possibility and your brain begins to
fire in new sequences and new patterns
and new combinations and you begin to
plan your behaviors and you begin to
review in your mind mentally rehearse
who you're going to be in your life the
mere action of mental rehearsal begins
to install the neurological circuits in
your brain now your brain is no longer a
record of the past
now it's in fact a map to the Future
and if you were then to begin to
emotionally embrace your future before
it's made manifest in other words
you're not waiting for your healing to
feel wholeness you're not waiting for
your new relationship to feel love
you're not waiting for the mystical
moment to feel awe you're not waiting
for your success to feel empowered
that's the old model of reality of cause
and effect in other words
the materialist
the person who's waiting for their
wealth to come to feel abundance
they're living by that model of cause
and effect but the quantum model is
about causing an effect which means you
begin to experience your own worthiness
and your abundance before it occurs you
have to feel wholeness in order for your
healing to occur we have to feel love
for ourselves and love for life in order
for us to have love in our life and so
then to instruct people how to teach
their body emotionally how that future
could feel like before it's made
manifest
if they do it properly their body is the
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're beginning to
Signal new genes in new ways that begins
to change their body to look like the
event has already occurred so the
process of change
in the meditative model requires
unlearning and relearning requires
breaking the habit of the old self and
Reinventing a new self
but we say in Neuroscience pruning
synaptic connections and sprouting new
connections unfiring and unwiring and
re-firing and rewiring
unmemorizing emotions that are stored in
the body and then reconditioning the
body to a new mind into a new motion no
longer signaling the same genes in the
same way but signaling new genes in new
ways
beginning to pull your energy out of the
past and beginning to invest your energy
into the future we really think that you
know everything's going to be handed to
us or we can get whatever we want
nothing's wrong with that that's really
cool that's really great but in the
creative process
you actually have to get outside of time
in order for you to be able to create
because if you're trying to predict
what's going to happen in the next
moment if you keep Romancing what
happens you're not in the present moment
The Familiar past is the known the
predictable future is the known
the present moment is the unknown that
is where all possibilities exist so yes
there is a function of three-dimensional
reality and Technology where more things
are happening in a shorter amount of
time certainly there's some type of
energetic thing that's taking place uh
in so many ways and to me that energy is
actually endorsing whoever you want to
be that's what I believe so if you want
to be a victim get ready because it's
going to get really good for you because
that energy is more available if you
want to heal wow there's a lot of people
healing now and they're using that
energy instrumentally in a positive way
so so yes there's a quickening that's
taking place and it's creating quite a
contrast or extremes that are taking
place in reality and the more extreme it
gets the more unstable the system right
so uh governments
um
um journalism
education religion medicine
uh everything's kind of falling apart
you know um and and it's very obvious to
people that has to happen for a new
Consciousness to emerge the thing is
we can't face these changes
uh programmed because we'll just add to
uh the chaos we actually have to be
relaxed and awake instead of stressed
out and unconscious and we have the data
to show that when you're relaxed and
awake amazing things can actually happen
to you instead of in survival stressed
out and in a program so in order to
create out something new we got to be we
got to be in the present moment and we
have to be outside that pace of where
everything's moving very quickly and and
Technology unfortunately is causing
people it's causing people to think uh
instead of them for them to think on
their own and I'm concerned about that
because
um
I never tell people what to think I I
want them to think for themselves I
think it's really important for us to
think for ourselves so there's an
acceleration that's taking place
energetically but I do think that that
acceleration is really just endorsing uh
uh who who you're being so Master the
moment and and learn how to be a Creator
I think that amazing things happen and
that's exactly what we're discovering
over and over again and just witnessing
the science
is absolutely supporting the that you
are greater than you think more powerful
than you know more and limited than you
can ever dream we have the data over and
over again that suggests that and the
testimonials that we have in hundreds of
people we have cancer researchers
standing on the stage with cancer
completely gone we see stage four
Cancers and bones and organs and liver
in the lungs com metastatic cancer just
doesn't typically go away
um very easily and out of the bones
there's no sign of it anywhere I mean
not once not twice over and over again
we had two people at an event that were
blind I wanted people to understand the
science and the relationship that they
have with their body that we have been
unconsciously programmed into believing
that
um something in our outer world has to
change our inner world and it's also
entirely possible when you start
changing your inner world you start
noticing the effects in your inner world
and sometimes in your outer world and
that's when we get really good at this
so I wanted people to understand how to
strengthen their immune system by giving
it the right information the right
emotions and just like we said it coax
the body into beginning to release
chemistry that begins to strengthen our
our T cells and our lymphocytes so one
is called uh empowering The Power Within
and the other one is called Falling Into
Love uh with your body and both of those
uh one's uh laying down meditation
before you go to bed and the other one
is a seated meditation that you could do
anytime and uh people have really
enjoyed them and there's the science of
course behind activating that force
center and the thymus gland and thymus
in that begins to activate T cells and
antibodies and put it all together and
try it out as I read your books walking
down the path of what's actually
happening inside your body when you're
having these healing moments where
you're healing yourself inside or you're
having these Transitions and
experiencing a negative thought or a
negative emotional feeling inside your
body
um can you give people something to
latch onto that allows them to
understand what that's supposed to feel
like and then how how obviously to walk
down the path to changing it look I mean
you have to think about this I mean the
fact that you can think about what
you're thinking about
makes you wonder
who's doing the observing of those
thoughts right the fact that you can be
aware of what you're thinking means
you're not the thought you're the
executor or the controller of that
thought you're the Consciousness that's
executing that thought so most people
think well just because I have a thought
it's true that's not true just because
you have a thought doesn't necessarily
mean it's true emotions and feelings are
a record of the past
so if you're feeling the familiar
emotions every single day of unhappiness
or unworthiness or insecurity then
you're starting your day from the past
and if those emotions are driving your
thoughts and you can't think greater
than how you feel then you're thinking
in the past and for the most part your
day is going to stay the same so the
first step
without a doubt Ben is getting people
the right information the more knowledge
you have in understanding how you work
and how your brain and body works in a
simple way the better you have the
operating manual to take care of
yourself our sexuality our consumption
of food our our ability to use our will
to overcome the conditions in our
environment most people live by these
centers here these are centers of
awareness centers of energy and each one
every thought that you have produces a
frequency so this is what we call the
zero point field it is the Quantum field
the unified field the energy that
connects everything material it is the
consciousness of the all in all it is
Oneness wholeness Universal Mind
infinite intelligence zero point field
the unified field Source Observer the
void the fertile void all possibilities
the Eternal now the infinite unknown the
very life force that holds everything
together and it's a unifying field and
scientists have been trying to unify the
principles and the energy of the
universe to explain how matter exists
are you with me still
so energy then the zero point field
slows down in frequency and it reaches a
certain point and at this level there's
an explosion called The Big Bang and all
of a sudden energy can't slow any
anymore before it divides and becomes
polarized and the patterns of everything
material exist at the speed of light and
it's the patterns then that slow energy
down to take form and structure that
ultimately appears matter now
all of us the Divine aspect of ourselves
came from this Universal intelligence
and we came all the way down into
density and this is the realm of our
senses and we can experience the
three-dimensional reality with our
senses and we spend our whole life being
a somebody or having some type of body
or knowing someone or being someone
owning certain things living somewhere
in some time and this becomes the
identity are you with me still
so then
people then spend the majority of their
life living in this way and they
experience from matter the greatest
separation from the unified field
here is source and if you're living as a
body local in space and time you're
experiencing a separation between you as
a Consciousness and the consciousness of
the unified field so when you're living
in a body and space and time it takes a
long time for your dreams to happen are
you with me still so if you're thinking
certain thoughts and certain thoughts
produce certain feelings you're taking a
thought and you're beginning to store it
as energy or emotion in one of these
centers and most people are thinking in
these first three centers and when they
do they're storing energy in their first
three centers and their bodies being
conditioned to be the mind
it takes opening this Center to begin to
the creative process this is the center
of Oneness this is the center of
wholeness this is the union of polarity
and Duality and if you can't get energy
into your heart then for the most part
then it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart to begin to affect the
nature of reality to begin to affect
matter are you with me still
so then every thought that you think
produces a frequency and most people's
frequencies most people's thoughts are
in this realm right here and would make
sense then if they're thinking flower
thought frequencies then it's going to
take a long time for their dreams to
come true what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our Awakening and connection
to the Divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't you can't do it the
same way because that's redundancy but
also many times we have the experience
and we start to try and because trying
is matter trying to change matter and
and so we're forcing we're controlling
we're predicting and and then the uh and
when we do that then of course we're in
separation and we're waiting for the
event to happen to feel the emotion
right and I've done that long enough and
is actually have to lay down
the very thing we used our whole life
that get what we want for something
greater to occur and it takes practice
of surrender right so
that's one element I also think that our
response is emotionally like uh uh uh
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the Future like it
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
it doesn't work that way so then then
when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
I fail they didn't do it right no that's
all the program you show up again and
you go after it again
so familiar feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and and and we color reality
that way so
um I think I think familiar emotions uh
get in the way as well and then of
course there's always belief and a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and it's called the memory the
moment they draw a conclusion about that
experience they'll think neurologically
within those circuits and they'll feel
chemically within the boundaries of
emotion thinking and feeling thinking
and feeling belief becomes an
unconscious or subconscious state of
being they don't most people don't even
know they have beliefs about things
about God about relationships about
money because it's it's not a conscious
thing it's a subconscious thing yeah so
in order to change a belief or a
perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in it's not like you
go 50 in you got to go all in you got to
make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say I remember the
moment
I made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge Stone you drop in the
quantum field Big Splash big waves
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules for Michael a singer
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you then I have a mind I
can do better with it than letting it
feel horror show and letting it scare me
all the time then letting it remind me
of everything never bothered me then
letting it worry about what will happen
10 years from now or 20 years from now